um i mean so so uh when you're on set do
you ever get anxiety with like lines and
things like that and like i have to be
good or you get
you know or that's something you've been
doing for so long that it probably
doesn't affect you like
that's your world it depends i mean it
obviously depends on the scene but
um no i feel like i that is where i kind
of
i my anxiety leaves a little bit um wow
it's weird that feels like
i don't know like comfort or something
work i mean obviously depending on the
scene or what we're getting into but
like
yeah i i i love working so much
um that that just it's it's a it's
almost like a comfort zone
wow yeah i think i've always with work
and everything i associate it with
anxiety i have to be anxious i have to
be
so disciplined i have to be great that
it's just like it drives me
crazy to the point where i and i work
so hard that that's what happens so i
really would like to um
eventually let that go more and try to
enjoy it more like i'm trying to enjoy
like
i like like enjoying these podcasts like
being able to put these headphones on
and just
talk to someone and enjoy it and not
think about oh
and all these other external things that
i can't control it's always about things
you can't control that give you anxiety
right absolutely yeah so you're you're
this is this is great you're very good
at this
are you saying i should quit acting